preparing for an emergency emergencies
can happen at any time that's why it's
so important to be prepared there are
lots of things you could do in advance
so if an emergency does happen you will
be ready to cope you can prepare for
damage to your home temporary evacuation
or isolation by putting together an
emergency grab bag with everything you
need in it this could hold important
personal information and items which
help in an emergency such as
prescription medicine details for the
family toiletries identity documents a
first-aid kit a radio either battery or
wind-up and a torch also either battery
or wind-up spare batteries a notebook
pen and pencil spare glasses or contact
lens a mobile phone charger contact
lists including phone numbers insurance
details spare keys for your house and
car and anything else you think is
important chocolate is always useful the
bag should be small enough for anyone to
carry and should be kept in a safe place
that everyone in your household can find
think about situations such as a fire
flooding power cuts or extreme weather
talk about them discuss and agree what
you would do its best to write down your
plan but even having discussed it can
make a huge difference to how you will
cope whether it's a minor incident or
something worse if there's a major
incident stay home and tune in to your
local radio BBC essays can be found at
10 3.5 and 95.3 on FM and heart FM can
be found at 10 2.6 in the north and the
middle of essex or 96.3 in the south of
essex go in saying and tuning your
health and recovery after an emergency
can be just as channel
Jing for more information about the
crisis support team in Essex visit w wh
0s org also there's lots more advice and
information on the Rochford district
council's website at www k /m urgencies
and there's some more contact that you
might find useful here w w sx hyphen
five WK w WS six police to UK WWD our
govt UK w NH str8 NHS UK RSPCA co uk and
ww environment hyphen agency gov't UK
the flood helpline is on 0845 9w 8
double one double eight and for
non-emergencies you can contact essex
police on 0300 three double three double
for double for
Roger District Council is warning
residents to beware of bogus callers
claiming to be from the council
fraudsters are calling residents
claiming that their council tax payments
are in credit then asking for their bank
details so that money can be transferred
back into their account the council
would not contact residents asking for
their personal bank details residents
are also advised to be on their guard
for other attempts to get them to part
with their personal details and in some
cases their cash as well as the
telephone scams tricksters will try
anything from calling unannounced at the
doorstep to stopping people in the
street under the guise of representing
legitimate organizations such as the
council and utility companies whatever
the approach their objective is the same
two prized personal information
especially bank details from unwary at
residents the council through the
Community Safety Partnership has also
become aware of approaches to local
residents by firms using questionable
tele sales tactics in some cases making
false claims that they're working with
the council or Essex Police typically
they will tempt people with offers of
free or cut price products then subject
them to a high-pressure sales pitch
aimed at selling them more expensive
items residents who receive a cold call
they believed to be questionable should
terminate the conversation immediately
on no account divulge any personal
information and report the call to
consumer direct on 0845 40 40 50 six
steps to tackle the phone fraudsters if
you receive a telephone call from
someone saying they're from the council
and asking for your bank details don't
divulge any personal details over the
phone call the police on 0300 3 double 3
double for double for
contact the council's community safety
team on 0 1 702 546 366
domestic abuse help support and advice
available domestic abuse can affect
anyone at any time of their lives
regardless of gender ethnicity sexuality
social background and increasingly age
research by the National Society for the
Prevention of Cruelty to Children s
NSPCC shows that violence in teenage
relationships is becoming more common
and that many teenagers take the
surprisingly tolerant attitude to this
violence equally an increasing number of
younger women including young mums find
themselves through force of
circumstances in unsuitable
relationships and feel unable to break
the cycle of abuse against this backdrop
the castle Poynton watched for domestic
abuse panel the AAP has launched a
leaflet and post the drive specifically
aimed at challenging these attitudes
among younger people and to signpost
help available to younger victims of
domestic abuse the leaflets and posters
have been designed with the help of
sixth form pupils from local schools
with graphics that reflect the younger
generations passion for new ways of
communicating and social networking
domestic abuse reduction officer for
Oxford District Council and chair of the
DA p Tracey Schneider said relationship
abuse is about one partner wanting to
dominate or manipulate the other
evolving technologies like mobile phones
and social networking sites are giving
perpetrators greater opportunities to
extend their control over victims we
wanted to show that we understood this
and through these posters and leaflets
send a clear message to victims of abuse
that they are not alone help is
available to them the leaflets and
posters have been distributed to housing
associations doctor surgeries and health
centers council offices and police
stations libraries and via schools a new
and discreet process for reporting
domestic abuse online has been launched
by Rochford District Council an easy to
file questionnaire has been designed for
use by victims of domestic abuse anyone
who has witnessed the mr. could be
or a third-party reporting an incident
on behalf of someone else all the
information provided is treated in
complete confidence as well as providing
a means of reporting abuse the
questionnaire will also include details
of where victims can find help the form
can be accessed via the Oxford Council
website at www k domestic abuse
reduction officer tres de Schneider said
the questionnaire will give us a better
understanding of the extent of the
problem locally while providing those
caught up in an abusive relationship
with access to the information they need
to find a way out additionally a call
back facility will be available to them
if they feel they need to talk to
somebody directly and confidentially the
questionnaire also provides others
concerned that someone is being abused
with the means to bring the issue to our
attention in a discreet way anonymously
if they wish many a life has been saved
by an interfering neighbor friend or
relative phone 07 920 264 610 or email
Tracy Schneider SCH any IDE are at
Rochford gulf qk
rochford district matters is edited by
patrick john and produced by rockford
district council who can be found at
three to nineteen south street rochford
SS for one BW their telephone number is
zero one seven zero to five four six
three six six and their website is at w
WH foods garvey UK and that brings us to
the end of this edition which was
recorded by volunteers from the rayleigh
Rochford and castle point talking
newspapers for the blind at this studio
in rochford